you want to call out cancel culture
we'll talk you know I think the you put
cancel culture and encyclopedia they
show a picture of what happened of you
and what happened to you they didn't
just get you fired you know removed from
your position they started going after
your legacy there was I think you you
had contributed to a university is that
what happened they took your name down
yes four four universities which ones
uofl UK Ball State and Purdue
so you had contributed to these
universities I took your names they took
your name off of these these places well
we believe in voluntary exchange we
believe that when you um go out and you
buy a product or service it's mutually
beneficial to all parties that's what
free markets do so the curriculum that
we set up in each University was free
markets voluntary exchange
entrepreneurship and we were up to four
universities
um the left and I won't make this
political but the left did not like us
in the universities and the group I went
in with
um and this was tens of millions of
dollars to do this we had two goals the
first goal is to give the kids both
sides of the coin they hear about
entitlement how good you know Big
Brother Big government it is you know if
you're successful that's not good you
don't have to be accountable a big
bureaucracy we flipped it and said okay
that's fine you want to believe that you
need to believe it or whatever but you
might look at entrepreneurship
accountability self-respect making a
contribution uh earning saving getting
ahead and then and so they the kids
loved the entrepreneur program they
really did and whether they went this
way or that way I don't care as long as
they could see both sides of the coin
that was goal number one goal number two
was don't further divide uh the country
the country's already divided this was
five six years ago let's don't further
divide the country and I really feel
like we were accomplishing that goal and
of course our terminology our
nomenclature the left couldn't get on it
because we were not there to divide we
were there just to teach free markets
and so I think the left really had an
issue with us going into these
universities and teaching free markets
free enterprise and Entrepreneurship wow
yeah you were having a I didn't even
know that yeah I just saw the story
where it's like name was removed from
school and I'm like that's crazy but now
it sounds like you were actually having
a very very powerful impact on young
people and teaching them personal
responsibility yeah the first the second
year at uofl out of 1263 curriculums our
program got was number four and within
two years so the kids love
entrepreneurship they they love hearing
about free markets and freedoms in
general and so when we were at four we
wanted to go to 400.
um because we think small business
um is the backbone in the heartbeat of
this country I mean 60 something percent
of the new jobs are small business so we
like Mike Rowe Dirty Jobs yeah we like
teaching vocations we like teaching
trades we like teaching entrepreneurship
I even went to the classroom on the
front of the building school and then
trades in the back how do you build a
house you know how do you work on a
truck you know how you do the technical
part of a carburetor on a Toyota or
whatever it is but we actually went to
the school room adjacent to the workshop
a micro kind of deal to teach these kids
how to have a career have a job so they
don't get out of college you know you
know 150 000 in debt on student loans do
you think that there was maybe a
political component to what happened to
you then I mean you've got you've got
special interests that don't want what
you're teaching kids in these
universities they certainly ripped that
out the moment they could well you're
asking the conspiracy question
um was well I guess as the conspiracy
Beyond just being set up by you know
people want to make money was there a
political component I you know I don't
want to say anything I really don't have
facts I know Richie and Shapiro were
part of it on a Washington with laundry
service as part of Goodell was probably
part of it how far up the food chain
that goes Washington's the head of the
DNC in in La I don't really want to make
that assumption I will say this I made a
comment it says Roger Goodell needs to
solve the NFL issues to the players in
owner satisfaction
less than 20 minutes
that went viral that I was against the
players kneeling I mean I'm like how did
they take that that was a lie a lie
benign an Oculus and turn it into
that I'm anti-nealing and within one
hour we had like six million it just
blew up so I'm kind of like was that
orchestrated well do you have you ever
heard of the phrase a standalone complex
yeah emergent yeah so a lot of people
you know conspiracy is a dirty word and
yeah I gotta be honest I'm fairly
anti-conspiracy in a lot of ways because
you need a lot of evidence to back up
these big stretches
however
when you tell a story like that that you
said you know solve this to the players
and the coaches benefits how you said
plays and coaches or play good L needs
to solve this debacle to the owners and
players satisfaction right right to take
that and clearly take it out of context
to make you look bad a standalone
complex would be when a bunch of people
do something that effectively acts in
concert to create the appearance of a
conspiracy but they're actually just
doing it independently so if you had 10
people who all stood up at the same time
and yelled that they were you know fans
of Papa John's people would assume they
orchestrated it that would be a
conspiracy they they sort of they came
together and planned it at 10 o'clock
we're all going to stand up and shout we
like pizza a standalone complex would be
seemingly by chance they all stood up at
the same time independent of each other
for some reason so when you see what
happened to you perhaps it doesn't need
to be a conspiracy it could just be that
when people saw there was an opportunity
to go after you political components
were like now's our chance to get rid of
these free enterprise programs in these
universities and so they did I think
that concept is definitely could be
applicable to my situation for this to
happen all the stars had to align
perfectly in the wrong way for me and
that could have happened that could have
happened regarding like building
entrepreneurial skills for young people
what was your young entrepreneurial
career like like when did you get your
first job and what led you up to start
making the pizzas the greatest lesson I
ever had was
um when I was eight my grandfather had
kind of like a farm miniature farm where
we had tractors and Moors and equipment
and um
he'd go out and buy new equipment and
tractors but every once while I would
break and like the motor would break on
the tractor and he would look at me and
say fix it and I said fix it well I'm
eight years old seven years old eight
years I'm gonna you know and he got so
I'd tear the motor apart tear the
carburetor apart on his workbench and
sometimes I could get it back together
and sometimes I couldn't he didn't care
he wanted me to know how things worked
you want to know how to how for me to
know how to turn a wrench to to
understand that the engineering the
mechanics of how things really work that
was by far you know how how do
ecosystems work how does the environment
work how does the weather work you know
how the political systems work how does
our economy work how does our banking
system work that all came back when I
was 78 years old when he wasn't both he
and my dad said it's okay to make a
mistake you know you're not going to
learn if you're not making mistakes now
don't make the same mistake twice but an
entrepreneur is
um nothing but a big shot's nothing but
a little shot that kept on shooting so
just keep on shooting keep on trying new
things and new Innovations keep
tinkering yeah go ahead yo you're being
taught to think critically to think
independently to be personally
responsible you tell that story and I'm
like well that makes perfect sense you
plant that seed and here you are this
very successful businessman
and then you look at the school programs
you you said that they were two
different programs right you wanted
people to be able to see both sides
yours was free enterprise what was the
other thing they were teaching what was
the other component big government
um tax the rich success is a Bad Thing
entitlements
um you know the the number one employer
for history majors in the United States
is Starbucks
yeah I mean they would teach they
wouldn't teach self science you know I
wanted to always teach hard science
arithmetic you know engineering a
veterinarian for example that would be a
great career
um how to build something architecture
you know those are things that are hard
scientists that you can actually do
something with and have a real career at
uofl we were we had 200 slots in our
Dentistry program and we had demand for
three thousand dentists I'm like
we need more dentists I mean you know we
don't need more lawyers we don't need
more social science folks we need more
Engineers we need more Architects we
need a dentist I'm curious as to how
this is happening how you could have the
the the program that espouses
Independence individuality
entrepreneurship that's the one that
gets removed I mean that should be the
resilient side of things right
you do have a way with turning things on
their head let me tell you what you just
said because you just did in real time
what you did back in 2018 you're right
they threw me out on something I didn't
say and the very thing that we're trying
to produce was exactly what I didn't say
so that's kind of interesting what what
I mean is if you teach people to be
responsible independent smart cunning
and to be good people to try and help
others how is it that that these are the
ideals that seem to be faltering you
know particularly in this story but in
in my experience I think a lot of people
are seeing it you tend to have the big
government you know entitlements
side becoming more and more prominent
gaining control of the institutions
maybe there's something that the uh
being a good person misses I'm not
saying don't be a good person
but maybe when you're a good person you
overlook the fact that some people might
be lying to you well
um again back to with your your audience
here on you know you gotta you gotta own
your own uh BS you got to own your own
nonsense and so the question for the
house is I mean I protected my board of
directors with my life I protected my
employees with my life
I protected my franchisees I mean I I
made sure that nothing was going to
happen to them and okay we we now have
established they want the 160 million
they want the marketing business they
want to you know so they want to get rid
of John live with that okay
um can we have a cup of coffee and say
John you go we'll go no conversation no
nothing
not only do you want to get rid of me
they wanted the crucifixion they wanted
to you know they wanted to pay me in a
racist now
that's evil I mean that is about as bad
as you can do to a founder of a pizza
company that did it by the book that
played the long dream and took everybody
up with it and the question before the
house is how come I didn't see that I
had no inclination that this board of
directors and this executive team would
do something like this not even a witch
that they were even capable of doing
this and they did it they continued to
do it and so what I've tried to get out
of this is okay how can I use that for
higher level of Consciousness awareness
why didn't I see it but then you got to
flip that on and said and go I don't
want to go around life going I got to
worry about people screw me every second
of the day so
um as you can see we haven't quite
reached the forgive the unforgivable
we're definitely off I'm going to kill
these people we're off that one which is
where we're at back here literally
um but it's uh it's a lot to take in
it's it's a lot to overcome but we we to
move on with the life we have to get to
that that forgiveness stage we have to
yeah it kind of feels like um people who
are trying to be nice and do good are
unsuspecting of you know what's going to
come after them and the story you tell
me about uh you know I know people who
worked Papa John's I said it was
fantastic I remember I was reading some
quotes where you were saying that you
know people got to get paid more the
minimum wage was too low I've heard you
you know you basically talked about
things that are fairly populist right
help for the for the little guy and for
the working class and sure enough maybe
you know I don't know how to describe it
but you you may be too nice you know
well you understand Papa John's and and
we we did build a great uh company but
we also had great people we had a great
team we really were more in the people
business and the pizza Fitness it was a
fantastic group of individuals and
that's how we got the thing over 5 000
Stores
um but I think you can't you know you
you just got to stay positive with us
and
um
I I think that if you take care of
people and you do the right thing then
sooner or later you know karma's karma's
a real deal I mean Karma you know what
goes around comes around you're
definitely right about forgiveness I
think we're about to enter the age of
like more transparency especially in
government and when we start changing
our government there's going to be we're
going to start finding all these crimes
and criminals within the politicians and
it's going to be really
you know people are really going to want
to punish them but I think we have to
forgive these people Hillary Clinton's
email scandals for instance we got to
forgive these people and make sure that
if we move forward to society it's all
together otherwise those rich people in
the shadows are going to try and avoid
getting caught and they're going to try
and do damage to the people attempting
to move the system forward so I'm full
with you about this forgiveness era
I mean some people are really really
dead yeah but really it's not for up to
us to decide in my opinion I I don't
think we can do it if we don't do it
together all of us as weird as it sounds
horrible if there's no justice for
horrible crimes then people lose faith
in the system because I've already lost
faith man because the justices you don't
you don't bring it back by saying bad
people get can get away with bad things
well good people you know the Ben
Franklin quote a hundred people guilty
people better to escape than one
innocent suffer I think that maybe
that's ten thousand guilties should
Escape rather than one innocent suffer
that is a hard question man because I
understand what you're saying if we if
we stay if if we stay with the rage and
the anger then we fall apart but if we
allow people to get away with evil then
you live in an evil Society not in the
future but for past crimes it's just an
idea yeah I think I think you'll end up
in an evil Society I think when people
when right and I don't think I don't
know if there's a real simple solution
to everything we're seeing I mean the
thanks for checking out this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time